orangutangs are unique among primates
and the way they move between trees that
was a clip from the National Geographic
series paradise islands viewers may
often wonder how such astounding footage
is actually filmed in this case and many
others it was shot by our next guest
Emmy Award winning wildlife photographer
James Aldrin has spent a career up in
the trees in jungles and forests across
the globe his life's work is documented
in his new book the man who climbed
trees James is with us good morning
welcome good morning thank you very much
so I just asked you you were 10 when you
first climbed a tree near you it would
have played some role in your life yes
what is it about the trees and these
giant features that you love so much I
think it's the energy really they're
sort of fountains of life aren't they
trees and they support a lot of
biodiversity they're just an opportunity
for looking at familiar landscapes from
a different perspective in many respects
you know when you climb up into their
branches it's yeah it's a nice physical
experience but it also takes you on a
mental and you know emotional journey
you've worked with one of the most
well-known voices and nature shows but
of course they're David Attenborough yes
and and you actually rigged up systems
so he could climb in trees mover I think
it was nerve-wracking you write about it
- why well it just just sort of hoisting
or or raising any other human being up
and having responsibility for their
safety is there he goes but with David
yes of course but and so we had that on
the counterbalance bosun's chair system
yeah I could winch him up yeah you David
at the end of her rope actually I'll put
a lot of safeties you know now I think
I'm quite a paranoid rigger it's not
it's not 10 year old climbing a tree
this is like more like climbing a
mountain everything is Anton earring and
caving and industrial rope techniques
because the trees they're the size of
buildings you know that some of them are
3035 story building you know looking at
all of this when when you're able to
show people this different perspective
from up high you think that's helping
people maybe appreciate nature and
conservatism a little bit more I think
so I mean it is one of the the few sort
of last truly unexplored
sort of biological frontiers on the
planet that the rainforest canopy so to
take people on their journey there and
particularly with the presenter as
gifted and talented as David
Attenborough they can communicate that
very very well so to be part of that you
know helping introduce people to new
environments and sort of you know in
January inspiration is nice we know when
you pop in the trees to get these shots
yeah quickly how long do you spend up
there it can be anything from a couple
of days to I've just come back from a
month in the Philippines where I was up
in a tree every day for four weeks don't
told us twelve hours a day to get the
footage so waiting is the hardest part
well I just I really enjoy it yeah it's
like waiting at a theatre for your
favorite actor to come out stage in my
in ten seconds or it could be ten days
you know Richard Burton now there's got
to be more danger than just getting up
there and in the book you write about
some crazy things that have happened
yeah it's a very dynamic environment the
rainforest as a high turnover of life
you know a lot of parasites a lot of
just very very dynamic things are
constantly changing and but that's part
and parcel of working there really
you've been attacked by African
honeybees charged up by elephants
illnesses it sounds terrible doesn't it
[Laughter]
yeah but it's just because over 20 years
it happens you know yeah because you're
entering at their environment you know a
lot of these places as a human being you
don't really belong there and you sort
of try to force yourself into it and an
ecosystem that gets on perfectly fine
without you and there are a lot of
things there that you do need to be
careful of any one more play I'm sure
there are many but next place that you
want to go and be able to capture oh I
would love to spend some time in the
Pacific north northwest actually up
around British Columbia that Brent the
temperate rainforests really really
interest me so maybe one day the book is
the man who climbs trees James Aldred
thank you so much for being with me was
a treat